i mean couldn't have been all
bad right
hey folks now my normal uh
tradition this time of year is to do uh
three lists uh one for the
10 best movies of the year just passed
and then
two videos for the year upcoming about
movies that i'm most excited for or that
i'm pretty sure will suck
i'm kind of scrapping the last two
completely because
even though i while i doubt the
release schedule is going to see as much
upheaval as 2020 did i just don't trust
it
right now and you know that that's just
annoying uh so until i have more
security in that i'm not going to do a
lot of things about the year coming
up i'm just going to deal with that as
it comes as if and as far as looking
back to 2020 goes
i am going to do that but i am not going
to restrict myself to movies or
theatrically released films
uh which is what i normally do i'm not
doing that this time because
honestly there weren't a lot
and well i there are certainly plenty of
ones that i'm sure are good that i
missed
i decided to broaden the category out
into just
any form of entertainment that was
released in 2020.
i i actually should just say movies or
tv
because like that implies video games
and while i did start playing some video
games again they're all like really old
because i have a ps3
anyways so i've expanded it out it's
still going to be a top
10 list hey there folks it's me from the
slight future quick interjection um
right after shooting this video i
actually
ended up watching something that was
made in 2020
and really ended up enjoying it and i am
now adding it to the video
and i didn't really want to balance any
of the stuff that i had already on here
so now this is a top 11.
because it is
all right let's go number 11
hamilton this one i'm sure there are
plenty of other people out there who
would put this one much
much much higher and while i actually
did like it a lot
i'm finally getting to see it once i got
disney plus
there are things about it like there's a
lot of legitimate criticisms about this
especially if you're going to tackle the
way that it treats
history i'm not just talking about
whether or not certain things are
historically accurate
there's just aspects to it in the way
that certain characters are depicted
that
i don't always completely roll with but
you know what the performances are great
the music's awesome
i really am impressed with some of the
way these performances are done
they captured it actually very well
staged shows
being done as movies oftentimes just end
up being very
boring this wasn't this was a really
well put together presentation of a very
good show and
i liked it a lot i was late to the
hamilton love train because
you know i never bought the soundtrack
and i definitely never saw it on stage
but uh happy to be here now
number 10 birds of prey
or the fantabulous emancipation of one
harley quinn
[ __ ] you forgot about this one didn't
you or if you remembered it you were
like that was 2020 yeah it was
pretty sure this was the last film i saw
in theaters
that year and actually remains to this
point the last movie i saw in theaters
we'll see what eventually breaks that
streak
once it's safe for me to actually start
going to theaters again
but i had a lot of fun with this movie
it is
so much better at depicting not only the
character of harley quinn but of making
good use of margot robbie's
interpretation
of the character it lets her set the
tone for the whole movie
i think that's part of the problem with
her use in suicide squad i mean there's
a lot of problems with suicide squad but
with her particularly
if you're going to have harley quinn you
kind of have to let her as a character
set the tone
otherwise she feels out of place or
underused
here she gets to dictate how this thing
feels how this thing looks
it's colorful it's fast it's funny i
like the performances i like
most of the alterations done to the
characters i find them to be
inventive and enjoyable i don't really
know why they call that one character
cassandra kane because like that's not
cassandra can at all but
still a good performance and and also
honestly really underrated villain as
well this was a good time
number nine the haunting of blind manor
now as a reminder i have not yet watched
all of haunting of hill house i am
actually trying to go back and redo it
but i'm taking it a
slowly and two with a with a spotter i'm
watching it with somebody else there so
that i can
basically have someone to decompress
with because that was part of why i
couldn't get through more than that
but without the baggage of hunting of
hill house i feel like i actually got
more enjoyment out of hunting of blind
manor than it seemed a lot of other
people
did because of the need to
compare it to hunting of hill house
which isn't necessarily an unfair thing
to do
it is a spiritual sequel you're allowed
to compare them but i didn't have that
baggage and i
found a lot to enjoy about this a lot
that i found
really interesting about the way that it
depicted
the ghosts and the motivations behind
them and
the way it got me to just skin
crawlingly
hate a certain character like i don't
remember the last time that i've
hated a character that much where it
didn't feel like a mistake usually if i
hate a carrot and i'm not going to name
them out of the interest of spoilers
but normally when i hate a character
that much it's because something went
like i don't want them in the
story like i hate their presence this
character absolutely belonged there
and i hated his guts
this was this was really good like i've
got a
couple of nitpicks on it in terms of its
resolution towards the end but i
really i really like this a lot and also
myself not being british the accents
didn't bug me so that probably helped
too
number eight hannah gatsby
douglas now i thought nanette
was brilliant did a whole video about
how brilliant i thought that show was no
matter what you thought of that show
the kind of statement that it was making
and the kind of thing that it was
that is a really hard thing to pick up
from and try and do a follow-up to
and yet i think hannah gatsby gives the
perfect follow-up to nanette
not trying to recreate it addressing
what nanette was
what it meant for her to do it the
fallout from it but also not having it
that be the entire basis of the show
either
finding new ways to tackle things
finding new elements new angles
and giving me as someone who is not on
the autism spectrum i feel like
a decent insight into what that kind of
experience is like i mean i i can't say
that i understand i never can that's not
how my brain works but i feel like i was
let in
in a way that other media that has
depicted autism
in some way has always felt like it
helped me in arm's length
she brought me in it made me understand
in a way that in the net she brought me
in and made me understand
her pain so i think it's a terrific
follow-up it is
very very funny and i'm not going to
recommend it to people who hated
nanette if you hate internet just just
don't bother but
if you thought there was good there if
you enjoyed it especially if you love
nanette and you haven't seen douglas yet
you need to number seven
umbrella academy season two there's a
bit of a surprise inclusion for me
because i
i didn't dislike season one all that
much but it didn't do much for me
i just watched and i'm like okay that
was a that was a thing
all right season two was my jam
again whole video on that one and how i
was able to really tune into this
thing's a wavelength this time it
brought in
the weirdness that i needed it to have
because while the first one had its
elements of weirdness it was a little
too
dark it took itself a little too
seriously this one still has serious
moments and is able to have strong
emotional path
but this one has a much better
understanding that it is ridiculous
on its face and most of these characters
are absurd
and it revels in it in a way that i am
so
excited about and i really really
enjoyed
from almost the instant it started this
to me was such an upgrade from the first
season it was a great time
number six the owl house
season one talked about that one
recently over in the break room of geeks
this is this is a really really good
show
and i i will default to what i said
there this is harry potter by way of
gravity falls
it has that vibe of exploring a
world of magic and of learning about it
and being coming more integrated into
that world
with a much higher degree of just weird
and i'm so here for all of it the
characters are great the lead character
is not the kind of blank slate you
usually get in a lot of stories like
this
loose has her own sense of personality
her own
needs and wants and desires she is
interesting in and of herself and then
you put her in a setting that is this
interesting
and you definitely have my intention
from the start
i had a lot of fun with this and i'm
really really
anticipating where they go with this in
future seasons
number five wolf walkers
i never did get around to reviews and
reviewing this one by itself but partly
because i don't
have that much to say about it other
than to say uh go watch it
it's really really really really good
it's
gorgeous for starters and i knew that
going in like i know this animation
studio i've been a fan of their work for
a while
but it's stunningly beautiful wonderful
characters
real heart at its core and
and here's the thing you can see it
for free it is on apple tv
and if you are not currently subscribed
to that service you can get a one week
free trial get on there watch it and
watch whatever else that's on the
service that you want to watch while
you're there
cancel your subscription before the week
is over you will not pay a cent you will
still see it
nobody has any excuse for not seeing
this movie it is
wonderful gorgeous uplifting just
terrific number four
disclosure i'm not a documentary
person i have a tendency to get
either bored or frustrated with them for
the most part
a lot of them have a tendency to not
delve into the stuff that i actually
find
interesting they brush by certain things
or they
they try to or they try to incorporate
too much and don't have proper
focus i just don't have a lot of time
for documentaries
disclosure really nailed what it was
going for i was honestly nervous
watching it because a lot of times when
i have watched
be it video essays or documentaries or
what have you
on lgbtq plus or in this case
specifically
transgender inclusion and history and
places in the media
i've come away disappointed
for one reason or another but
this made first of all the brilliant
decision that every single person whose
voice we hear in his face we see
is themselves transgender it feels
truly like trans people telling of their
own stories their stories of
self-discovery their stories of seeing
themselves in media or
failing to see themselves in media and
what that feels like because that is
something i absolutely relate to
and i could connect with and understand
not only seeing
my experience reflected back at me
accurately
by the people who they spoke with and
the way in which the whole thing is
presented
but also giving me insight to people
whose experiences
are not dissimilar from mine but are
still distinctly different this is a
wonderful documentary
even if you yourself are trans or you
think you are really up to
date and like well-versed in trans
issues and you haven't watched it yet
you should and if you
don't know a lot of trans people and you
yourself aren't trans you absolutely
should watch it because
maybe it'll give you a better sense of
what it's like for us in the
fairly narrow category of seeing
ourselves depicted
on a screen it's the kind of focus that
i need from a documentary it was the
perfect focus for this one
watch it if you haven't a quick shout
out for some honorable mentions now
these are ones that didn't quite make
the list but were in contention
and those include the old guard which
was
definitely way better than it had any
right to be ultimately it's not the kind
of thing that i'm gonna come back to
often enough that i felt it really had a
place on the list proper but
had a lot of really neat ideas and
charlize they're on kick and butt is
always a good thing
castlevania season three not quite up to
the standards of season two but
still a surprisingly good follow-up i
wasn't sure that it could carry on from
season two but
it did and it was good and creepy
and i like it onward i have a lot of
world building nitpicks with this but
the actual
emotional core of the story is really
really solid the relationships between
the characters
and the way that it ultimately pays off
the familial story that it's telling
is really really well done bill and ted
face the music
this one was honestly never in that
serious contention for a place on the
list proper
but i think it was a really heartfelt
and sweet follow-up to a series that i
didn't
think it would be a good idea to come
back and revisit but i managed to do
that
all the same i like the conclusion i had
a lot of fun seeing these characters
again it was just a good time
and finally something that technically
is would not qualify for the list
because it didn't come into existence
this year but uh
shout out to among us i know i kind of
said that i don't really play modern
video games anymore but i did
i did get into that one a little bit you
know what it's a good way to unwind
it's a fun time and who knew that
us all being stuck in places and
feeling like there was something that
was being passed among us that was
going to wipe us all out would somehow
be in the zeitgeist
all of a sudden huh don't know why that
happened but
it's a good time it's a fun game i
played the mobile version for a while
i did eventually get the pc version
where i've now actually like played it
proper
not just in a random public match but
like with an arranged thing
with other people oh it gets
better when you play it that way game of
the year 2020. i don't care what year it
came out
okay back to the list proper number
three
hey it's me again which means this is
where i get to jump in and talk about
the thing that i watched
after having shot the video originally
i watched seoul on disney plus
i didn't think this was going to be on
my list i don't hold pixar in quite
the same level of esteem that a lot of
people do
i like pixar don't get me wrong but more
often than not i
like their stuff but i don't love their
stuff
and i will freely admit that part of why
i liked soul as much as i did
might have had to do with the fact that
i
watched it when i wasn't
really in a great mood uh after i had
shot
the original version of this video i i
had a i had a rough day
and some of that may have contributed to
how much i like this
there should be a full review up in the
break room by now
but long story short i found this
heartfelt and touching
and it hit me in the best way
it really nailed the emotions that it
went for
in terms of finding joy
in just living especially after a year
like 2020
that was something i was really happy to
see
delivered so well if you haven't seen it
yet
you really should number two
the good place season four
it is so hard to
end well i mean we've seen in the last
few years how many things have botched
their endings from game of thrones to
star wars
it's really hard
to nail the landing
but good place absolutely did
it took this idea in these characters
that are
funny and entertaining but philosophical
existential even and found a way
to bring it all to a satisfying
conclusion this was something like i
don't know how they can
possibly end this this is the perfect
way to end this
again did a whole video on it
the way that everything wraps up the way
the characters are
are sent off and the way that things
conclude in terms of a
feel that something can have a sense of
finality
while still feeling
yeah that is wonderful
and that was absolutely something i
needed this year
i think a lot of us did doesn't quite
take the number one spot
it's possible that the good play season
four is
the best written and most impressive
piece of work
you know from a uh construction
standpoint and everything else but it
didn't hit
me quite the same as
number one she-ra and the princesses of
power
season five
i love
almost everything about this
i'm not going to say that i have
absolutely no nitpicks i had a couple
when i did my review
but like i did multiple videos
on this for a reason because
i love these characters
i love the sense of
friendship and hope and struggle
and triumph of this
show it has characters that i
hold dear to my core it was one of the
main things i got to
you know have to do with my daughter
for a while the queerness of it and the
explicit
demonstration of non-heterosexual
romantic love between the leads at the
end
was wonderful but it was icing on a cake
because i already
loved this thing so
much i can't even begin to tell you
how wonderful this thing was
and how beautifully it managed to wrap
up
shira season five is my favorite piece
of entertainment
that came out in 2020. what would be on
your list
whatever it is feel free to include
things like video games or only do a top
five or
heck it's your list do however you want
go ahead and drop it down in the
comments
let's talk about it of course feel free
to leave your comments on my list
as well all of that uh is very
very welcome i have a patreon in 2020 i
lost my job
and this is now actually what i do for a
living and it's because of the patreon
that i'm able to pay my bills
any amount you are able to support keeps
the lights on
and keeps me fed but even if you're not
able to do that
liking sharing subscribing all that
helps as well
so i would greatly appreciate it
but you also don't have to end of the
day
you are the council and i am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]